en un vídeo anterior encontramos cómo
calcular el área de la superficie de
esta caja de cereal calculando el área
de las seis superficies que la componen
y luego sumando las todas voy a hacer lo
mismo en este vídeo pero voy a
realizarlo mediante una plantilla o red
de la caja a qué me refiero con esto de
una plantilla de la caja bueno una
plantilla sería imaginarnos cómo se
vería esta caja si la cortamos de manera
que quedara plana es decir podemos
imaginarnos hacer un corte en la caja
este corte sería aquí atrás
también puedo cortarla así
y cortarla así si yo hiciera esto esta
parte de arriba
esta tapa se abriría podría salir así
y también podría ser un corte de este
lado y hacer otro corte por acá de
manera que esta cara la puedo hacer
hacia adelante y si hago lo mismo de
este otro lado pues esta superficie
puedo moverla hacia el frente
y en la parte de atrás puedo cortar la
voy a dibujar esta línea punteada porque
realmente no podemos ver la parte de
atrás de la caja así que el corte
correspondiente de este lado que no
podemos ver y que creo que voy a volver
a dibujar un poquito mejor
el corte correspondiente es este de aquí
atrás justo aquí qué va a pasar con esta
caja si la aplastamos y la dejamos plana
pues tendremos el frente de la caja y
voy a tratar de dibujar lo mejor que yo
pueda tenemos esta etapa de aquí arriba
aplastada
que se ve así también tenemos estos dos
lados que los podemos traer al frente y
se ven así este es uno de los lados este
es otro lado después tendríamos la base
de la caja
esa base se ve así y tenemos la parte de
atrás de la caja que va a estar
conectada con la base
esa parte no la cortamos
así que la parte de atrás de la caja
queda así
y listo ya tenemos la red esto es lo que
pasa si hacemos los cortes que les
mencioné y aplastamos la caja cómo
podemos usar esta plantilla para
encontrar el área de la superficie pues
vamos a calcular el área de esta figura
como lo hacemos bueno conocemos muchas
de sus dimensiones sabemos que este
ancho de aquí mide 10 centímetros de
aquí acá sabemos la altura de aquí hasta
arriba porque la altura de la caja es de
20 centímetros
aquí tenemos 20 centímetros aquí arriba
tenemos otros 20 centímetros en esta
parte de acá
y la profundidad de la caja es de 3
centímetros así que esto de aquí en mide
3 centímetros
y esto de acá también mide 3 centímetros
bueno vamos a calcular primero el área
de una región que sería esta región de
acá
que estoy resaltando con azul
la base mide 10 centímetros
multiplicado por la altura y cuál es
esta pues será 20 más 320 3 que va a ser
40 6 46 centímetros
es el área de esta región azul 460
centímetros cuadrados y ahora nos falta
encontrar el área de estos dos lados
este lado de aquí tiene un área de 20
centímetros por 3 centímetros por lo que
es 60 centímetros cuadrados
y este otro lado va a tener exactamente
la misma área
otros 60 centímetros cuadrados
sumamos todo y vamos a tener el área
total de la caja
todo esto nos va a dar 580 centímetros
cuadrados que es lo mismo que obtuvimos
en el vídeo anterior en donde no usamos
una plantilla y es bueno poder resolver
este problema de dos maneras diferentes
usando una red o visualizando los
diferentes lados que tiene la caja aún
aquellos que no necesariamente
observamos